the house ago Iran - beautiful and
welcome to hunt slender game I played
this before one time and I wanted to
play it again and this time I'm doing it
when the heartbeat sensor I got my pulse
running up already holy [ __ ]
let's go what would you do if you woke
up in a place you've never seen me I
would probably start breakdancing did I
say that last time [ __ ] my imagination
sucks alright so as you can see they
actually proved on it a lot I have hands
now this is really impressive for a
couple of indeed people to make a free
game
I'd say it's [ __ ] awesome I don't
know how they do it though haha and why
it's free I don't know it's cool anyway
at the janab again let's say about
yourself it's supposed to be a bit
scarier this time around now we're
playing on the hardest difficulty
alright
there you are truck
yeah somebody should be near
project heart as you are aware of that
action than composites in [ __ ] alright
forgot the batteries we got the photo
and jump-scare MEMS cake good I know a
lot of you bros are scared by this I
don't know why whoa Oh big dumb [ __ ] Oh
baby
oh mama Oh baby sweet mama baby [ __ ] me
I'm fine
whoa Bob bunk what what why are we back
here right in the heavens but an air
where's your mom where's my mom where's
Shay mom mom I need you close the door
I'm pretty sure I did this pretty
[ __ ] sure I did that pretty [ __ ]
sure I did that wow these guys are
[ __ ] awesome III want to kiss them
they're facing Jade says and I want to
slap their faces at the same time it's a
love-hate relationship we got going okay
let's get going here's a map [ __ ]
grey lady night no look everything's
gonna be jab Lake near Dodge
obvious what the thought what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] was the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what the he's fast is a [ __ ] sprinter
I thought he was teleporting he is
teleporting and sprinting oh I'm just in
the [ __ ] forest now I bet he planned
this all along
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I shouldn't scream
that I'm sorry
Oh what the [ __ ] is a coming from I
haven't even got to know jack [ __ ]
alright don't worry don't worry I know
exactly what I'm I'm just [ __ ] where
am I
I don't even know did I get teleported
back jumps go ahead you guys scared of
that ha ha ha ha yep si I'm just kidding
all right let's keep going let's keep
going
what what is this it's this I found a
road browse I found myself a road
now which way Ola Dola Duff can't get
lonely cough cough a lonely binky Bonnie
Hulan doula that's why doth that's where
it is the right way I'll shed another
cross Oh little dump kick about a couple
other big about it we'll go da best way
bras whoa
I found the house finally hey how can ya
there's someone there someone up there
girl girl I go in the house what what
stop teleporting me slender this place
feels creepy oh [ __ ] I heard something
upstairs oh [ __ ] Oh what the [ __ ]
we're going out we got the case gums gay
look out - where by my step again what
is this pain want dead cool bowels whoa
ah
well that didn't go so well didn't oh
[ __ ]
let's try this again let's start on the
regular one what would you do if you
woke up in a place you have never seen
before
I would fat furiously I'll just sit down
and fat why is there static already look
at that gorgeous alright another journey
oh [ __ ] well is that slender screams
like a girl apparently I guess we have
one thing in common that's nice
did you hear that I can relate to you
slender alright here's the house my
house in the middle of the penis my
house what the [ __ ] is going on in there
I don't even want to know now Mario Bros
hahaha [ __ ] wad
I'm glad I have you flashlight at least
you are my only friend I ain't your pet
it
well there are my only friend - one I
don't even know where to go all right
look out boy look out this way
excellent till four five all day watch
I'm jogging like a boss jogging like a
boss being out of breath like about bout
um going up here we got to go up this
[ __ ] tower dump scary okay
get in what are you doing here he can't
he can't be in the stairs right like I
should be safe up here right
there you are
oh [ __ ]
I got us note I got a note [ __ ]
I got a note white one whoa [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's waiting for me
what the bog
no why no no bueno
I'm done that was a good try I got one
note I sucked I'd suck so much but this
game is awesome go and check it out I'll
leave it another link in the description
like they meant a such a good game with
this I think it's really cool really
thumbs up for that
I like a favor if you enjoyed subscribe
to come abroad today and I'll see you in
next episode
oh wow did I say that you're look
Freddy's today well II you know it now
sandbox